I think so many technology companies are
trying to solve problems of people who
live in like a few specific cities of
this particular country when in reality
building the future that we want or that
we'd be proud to hand to our kids
involves Humanity solving problems at
global scale
[Music]
right this is zipline drone delivery the
startup founded in 2014 helped build
hype for a future filled with packages
falling conveniently from the sky as
that future becomes more of a reality
zipline will have to compete with the
likes of Amazon's Prime air let me show
you something oh my God remember when
Jeff Bezos unveiled an octocopter on 60
Minutes these are octocopters that was a
decade ago no octocopters yet but Amazon
is making slow progress and alphabet's
Wing is getting off the ground as
[Music]
well hello hello hey thank you for
coming to see you no it's good to see
you again it's been a while welcome to
zipline we serve eight countries today
we serve about 3500 hospitals and health
facilities globally it's become the
largest commercial autonomous system on
Earth zipline honed its technology first
in Rwanda delivering blood vaccines and
other medical supplies especially to
rural areas that were previously poorly
served by land does that like give you
chills that you guys are out there
saving lives it definitely never gets
old especially when we get to G spend
time with doctors meet patients who are
benefiting from the system and it's been
really cool to see the system scale can
you show us how the magic happens yeah
let's do
it so this is zip Line's main
manufacturing area zipline has two
products today platform one is really
focused on Enterprise delivery platform
two we're launching with customers in a
few months so that's the one that's
going to be delivering all the packages
to my door yep exactly we're pretty full
stack company we're building lrus or
line replaceable units so basically the
subassemblies of the aircraft it all
happens here
yeah you can think of this as like the
ears of the aircraft so we're passing a
huge amount of air through here it's
like a really quiet wind tunnel this is
the paraland tube if we're encountering
such insane weather conditions or
there's like systematic failure
throughout the entire aircraft and
across multiple levels of redundancy
then we can deploy the parachute so we
can bring the aircraft gently to the
ground this is the reason that through
50 million commercial autonomous miles
zipline has had zero human safety
incidents see these two holes you're
going to line those up with those two I
think I can do it nice you did it good
job not heavy at all yeah or you're
really
strong this is the advantage of carbon
fiber materials you can design something
that's really strong it's designed to go
up to about 3 G's of
[Music]
load where we are now we call it Nest
zero this is actually the first test
site what's the grand plan when we
started building zipline the more we
thought about logistics the more we
realized Global Logistics really only
does a good job of serving people in the
golden billion so you know the richest
billion people on Earth your access is
probably okay but for the seven billion
people who don't fall into that category
your access either sucks or is
non-existent and as a result of that 5
and a half million kids under the age of
five lose their lives every year due to
lack of access to basic medical products
from a mission perspective what's
exciting to us about building an
automated Logistics system is that will
be the first Logistics system that
serves all people equally it will enable
us to transition Logistics to zero
emission it'll also enable universal
access to a lot of different products
including life-saving products so not to
overly simplify it but is it the goal to
be like a modern day UPS or FedEx or is
this something bigger I actually think
the opportunity to build a system that
is 10 times faster half the cost zero
emission and broadly available to every
human on earth is probably like 10 times
or
larger Emily this is Fabiola hi I
started a zip plan four years and few
months and it was Rwanda 1 yes it's
basically members of the Rwanda and
Ghana flight operations teams now having
to train all of our us team members on
how to do this at
scale getting
Ms no I want to in three 2 one all
[Music]
right that's
amazing ton of T-shirt oh t-shirts guys
and water so prepared so it's the goal
to deliver everything
from blood to vaccines to my Kleenex and
Sushi I mean it turns out that our
customers want everything in the US a
good analogy and with Walmart we had
initially planned to launch with them
around their Pharmacy business they're
one of the largest pharmacies in the US
we launched delivering Healthcare
products but very rapidly it was clear
that customers wanted to order
everything and so today we deliver like
24,000 of the 29,000 SKS in the store
that we're attached to you do have
competition Amazon Prime air alphab Wing
what makes you think you can lead this
Market I think there are a lot of big
companies with kind of infinite
resources talking about this Market but
you know talk and walk are different
things we are the largest commercial
autonomous system on Earth of any kind
ground or air so compared to Amazon you
know a lot less I you know you you
you'll have to ask them that question
zip Line's first delivery drones were
all about getting supplies to places
with enough space to drop packages from
midair to the ground the company's
platform too is all about precision and
reaching more dense urban areas one of
the most important things about making
the overall system work is how do we
integrate with all the different
companies that want to take advantage of
this to essentially enable teleportation
from their businesses or warehouses or
stores directly to a home zipline can
basically show up and install a magical
portal in your wall that's kind of how
we talk about it Harry Potter door yeah
yeah I think it was like Rick and Morty
you can basically choose what you want
to load do you have any preferences I
mean pizza and coffee pizza and coffee
okay everyone has to have pizza and
coffee right so I'll I'll put the pizza
in here and you can do the coffee okay I
mean is this going to spill in there
okay all right there you go so you just
teleported something via zip line that's
it pretty cool we need to be able to
deliver silently with dinner plate level
accuracy this is is the only thing
that's coming close to you your family
your house it's really cute it's not
making very much noise it's totally
safe what's going to happen to the UPS
guy I mean what about jobs any new
technology there's always this worry
that it's going to like put people out
of jobs so I think the reality is like
we're in a world where unemployment is
you know the lowest basically it has
been over the last 30 years generally I
think there are not enough humans to do
the work and labor that we want done to
live like abundant Rich lives
[Music]